so I'm going to show you what valerant
Esports used to look like so to set the
stage It Is 2020 it is like late 2020
the game came out in April now we're in
the meat and potatoes of valerin Esports
AKA valerant First Strike so out of the
40 players that played in this
tournament only five are now currently
signed to a team and that would be
Austina crashy Dapper Saia and Victor
Saia player went by spider here Victor
went by food and there's a player bra
who was formerly known as swag if swag
sounds familiar it should
what is this this kid a amazing sa this
pre-fired angels that don't exist 100
thieves actually won the tournament and
it was played on patch 1.12 so eons ago
at this point to put this into
perspective I didn't even know this game
was a thing so playing catchup and
learning about this is kind of like oh
we've come a long way